maurice leroy bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes bien à moscou et à paris
comme comme je le disais vous avez vécu
avec nous un 76e anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous retenez de ce
défilé militaire et de ses débuts de
cérémonie bonjour tout à fait c'est ça
c'est très émouvant de voir non
seulement ce défilé cette très belle
parade militaire mais surtout les
vétérans moi je suis très touchée par
l'image des vétérans qui ont vécu cette
guerre et qui sont encore présents
j'étais il ya peu de temps à volgograd
donc pour commémorer les morts de la
terrible et douloureuse bataille de
stalingrad et là il y avait un vétéran
qui avait participé à cette bataille
c'était très émouvant très
impressionnant nous y étions avec
plusieurs chefs d'entreprises français
gilles rémy qui était sur votre antenne
je crois ce matin le président de la
chambre de commerce d'industrie êtes
bien voulu citer emmanuel quidet et
participent à ces cérémonies et
représente les entreprises françaises
donc il faut rappeler pour vos auditeurs
que et le président qui des deux villes
très régulièrement que la france pour le
savoir les entreprises françaises sont
le premier employeur étranger en russie
donc c'est très important pour nous
français qui vivons qui travaillons en
russie d'être à côté de nos amis russes
pour commémorer ce souvenir
faut vraiment mesuré que ya pas une
famille où il n'y a pas eu de mort où on
n'a pas été touché par ce second conflit
mondial donc c'est très important je le
dis pour nos amis français parce que
hier c'était le 8 mai chez nous mais ici
c'est une vraie tradition les gens
s'écrivent se félicite se congratulent
envoient des messages très chaleureux
j'en ai aussi moi même dans les familles
donc c'est vraiment vécu il faut
ressentir ça j'essaie de vous faire
partager ça c'est pas seulement une
commémoration militaire c'est un vrai
une vraie cérémonie du souvenir de la
mémoire qui imprègne toutes les familles
y compris les jeunes compris la jeunesse
ce qui me marque aussi celle les jeunes
sont impliqués sont touchés par cette
cérémonie
maurice leroy vous vous parliez à
l'instant toutes ces familles touchées
par la seconde guerre mondiale justement
en quoi à cette journée est
particulièrement importante pour le
peuple russe
elle est importante parce que les
familles se souviennent se réunissent se
rassemblent et suivent d'ailleurs à la
télévision beaucoup pour ce parce qu'à
cause de la pandémie comme vous savez
tout le monde ne peut pas être sur la
place rouge
par rapport à ce qui se passait il ya
deux ans notamment on vit ça aussi dans
les cérémonies du 8 mai j'ai regardé ce
qui se passait chez moi en loir-et-cher
et en vendent au moins la ville de
vendôme dont j'ai été longtemps le
député j'ai vu que voilà il y avait il
n'y avait pas non plus la population
puisque du fait de la pandémie on ne
peut pas encore avoir de manifestations
publiques
et c'est aussi un peu le cas ici à
moscou mais du coup de ces vécus dans
les familles les gens se réunissent sont
en famille il ya habituellement ce set
extraordinaire des filets qu'on appelle
des immortels j ai participé il ya deux
ans et je vous assure que c'était très
émouvant impressionnant devant toutes
ces familles c'est populaire c'est
simple les gens sont étaient dans la rue
avec des portraits ça ne peut pas avoir
lieu cette année ça n'a pas eu lieu
l'année dernière toujours à cause de la
qu'ovide et de la pandémie mais c'est
très émouvant donc c'est cette fête de
la victoire puisque c'est son nom
cette fête de la victoire elle est vécue
par les familles et par tout le peuple
russe donc c'est très très important et
c'est très émouvant de d'y participer
quels sont les stigmates que la seconde
guerre mondiale a laissé en russie
d'abord je pense que la force du symbole
et c'est une occasion de se rassembler
de dépasser les différences c'est cela
aussi que montre cette belle parade avec
ce défilé très populaire
en vérité donc voilà je pense qu'en fait
on
comment vous dire moi j'ai un petit
regret c'est que on devrait aujourd'hui
avoir une communion internationale
autour de cette belle fête de la
victoire sur le nazisme sur la barbarie
nazie le racisme
et ça ça devrait rassembler
internationalement je regrette que les
tensions et là ce qui existe ne
permettent pas ça plus la pandémie qui
là est une réalité objective donc vous
parler des stigmates ses stigmates
il existe encore une fois vos reporter
donc très bien dit je les dis moi même
il faut le répéter le marteler sans
cesse tant de morts encore une fois je
reviens sur la label cérémonie que nous
avons eue grâce à pierre malinowski son
organisation parfaite
il ya eu d'ailleurs un très beau
reportage sur france 2 hier soir merci à
france 2 d'avoir fait ce magnifique
reportage très émouvant vous vous rendez
compte dans l'une des tombes dans les
fouilles qui ont été faites par pierre
malinowski et puis de les français qui
ont participé à ces fouilles des
étudiants notamment
eh bien on retrouvait le corps d'un d'un
adolescent de 16 ans qui était enterrée
avec d'autres soldats russes
encore une fois pas une famille qui
n'ait été touchés donc c'est c'est très
fort c'est plus qu'un défilé ou une
parade militaire c'est un une vraie
force populaire un vrai sentiment
populaire et là aussi je le redis dans
les familles c'est vibrant de toutes les
générations toutes les générations sont
concernés
regardez dans vos images on voyait
beaucoup de jeunes dans les rues venir
voir le défilé
ils sont avec le papa la maman le
grand-père la grand mère voilà c'est un
vrai rassemblement et c'est dommage que
la pandémie en pêche et on peut le
comprendre pour des raisons de sécurité
sanitaire bien compréhensible c'est bien
dommage que l'on puisse pas vivre mais
vivement qu'on puisse le faire de
nouveau ce ce défilé populaire simple
familiale qui s'appelle les immortels
c'est un nom magnifique d'avoir donné le
nom des immortels et les gens viennent
avec un portrait dans la famille des
leurs qui sont morts qui ont été blessés
ou qui sont morts dans ce terrible
second conflit mondial
donc c'est très très émouvant et
notamment avec ses vétérans qui
entouraient le président vladimir
poutine voilà ce que c'est très émouvant
de devoir cela moi j'ai pu y participer
il ya deux ans j'étais il ya deux ans
sur la place rouge vous assure que c'est
très fort comme sentiment voilà beaucoup
d'émotion c'est en tout cas ce que vous
nous dites merci beaucoup
un mort il sera d'avoir été avec nous
pour cette journée spéciale je rappelle
que je rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ministre de la ville et ex député u10 du
loir-et-cher est actuellement membre du
conseil d'administration de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie franco russe
merci à vous pour votre présence
avec nous aujourd'hui